MATTHEW SPALDING: Good evening.
Welcome to the Washington, DC
campus of Hillsdale College.
I'm Matthew Spalding.
I'm the Kirby chair of
constitutional government.
And I'm also the
dean of our programs
here in Washington, DC, where
we teach undergraduates.
And soon, we'll be starting
a graduate school here
in Washington, DC, as well.
Of course, Hillsdale
College is not
in Washington, DC,
[INAUDIBLE] observers of you.
It's in Hillsdale, Michigan.
It's an old college,
founded, if I might note,
just as a point of
reference, coincidentally,
founded the same year, 1844,
as Notre Dame was chartered
in Indiana.
Because of Hillsdale's
unique history,
it was the first college
to prohibit its charter
getting discrimination based
on race, religion, or sex.
It was an early proponent
of the abolition of slavery,
and to this day,
takes no federal money
to maintain its moral,
intellectual independence.
Because of all those
things, Hillsdale
has always emphasized
not only the teaching
of the liberal arts,
but the teaching
of those things necessary
for the perpetuation
of civil and religious liberty.
And that means understanding
the principles and practices
of self-government.
Indeed, as part of
our core, we require
every student of
Hillsdale College
to take a class on the United
States Constitution, which
brings me to our
event this evening
and our conversation with the
Honorable Amy Coney Barrett.
Judge Barrett is a
graduate of Rhodes College,
with a BA in English
literature, which I point out,
as I was telling her
earlier, further evidence
that liberal arts are a
proper and good foundation
for good legal reasoning.
She serves on the faculty of
Notre Dame Law School, where
she earned her JD,
summa cum laude,
and was a law clerk for Judge
Laurence Silberman of the US
Court of Appeals
for the DC Circuit
and for Associate
Justice Antonin
Scalia of the US Supreme Court.
From 2010 to 2016, she served
by appointment of Chief Justice
John Roberts on the
Advisory Committee
for the Federal Rules
of Appellate Procedure.
She's written for
constitutional law
and statutory interpretation
in numerous journals,
law journals.
And as we were
discussing earlier,
she still teaches one course
every semester at Notre Dame.
And she was appointed to the
United States Court of Appeals
for the Seventh Circuit
in November of 2017.
After a few prepared
remarks, she
will be interviewed this
evening by Stephanie Maloney.
Stephanie is an
appellate associate
in the Washington, DC
office of Winston & Strawn.
She served as a law clerk
with Judge Edith Clement
of the United States Court of
Appeals for the Fifth Circuit
and Judge Stephen Murphy of the
United States District Court
for the Eastern
District of Michigan.
She graduated Notre
Dame Law School,
where she was a student
of then-professor Barrett.
So with that, Judge Barrett,
welcome to Hillsdale College.
[APPLAUSE]
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Thanks
so much to Dr. Spalding
for organizing this event.
I am delighted to be
with you this evening.
I am a big fan of
Hillsdale College.
I've interacted with Hillsdale
faculty and students and alumni
in both social and
academic contexts.
And I am very impressed
with the education
that Hillsdale has on offer.
So I'm particularly delighted
to be with you here tonight.
I'm going to talk this evening
about the obligations of duty
in the face of
private preferences,
and the obligation
of duty in the face
of intense public
pressure to the contrary.
And I'm going to
begin with a story
from the revolutionary
war hero--
John Adams' representation
of the British soldiers who
had been involved in
the Boston Massacre.
The Boston Massacre
happened in 1770.
At that point, tensions
between the British colonists--
I'm going to move
this microphone over--
British colonists and
the Crown were rising.
So tensions were high.
And British soldiers
were stationed in Boston.
And there was no love lost
between the British soldiers
and the Bostonians.
The Boston Massacre became--
and those of you who
have been to Boston
and done the Freedom Trail
have seen the site of this.
The Bostonians were
taunting the soldiers
who were stationed there.
And what began in
taunts then turned
into a crowd of
300 to 400 people,
erupted into more
taunting and violence.
And it ended when the British
soldiers shot into the crowd,
killing five people.
The soldiers were
charged with murder.
And there was little
public sympathy for them,
to say the least.
There was a lot
of public pressure
for them to simply be lynched.
They couldn't find
counsel to represent them.
And then John Adams stepped up.
Now, obviously, John
Adams was a patriot.
So he couldn't have felt
a lot of personal sympathy
for the British soldiers.
His sympathies were
not allied with theirs.
But he believed
that it was vital
that the British soldiers
received a fair trial.
He believed that the American
cause for self-government
would be harmed if Boston
justice was not truly just.
And so he agreed to
represent the soldiers.
Yet he was reviled by many
Bostonians for doing so.
He faced intense public
pressure about that decision,
about his choice to
represent the enemy.
And here's what Adams
himself had to say about it.
"I had devoted myself to
endless labor and anxiety,
if not to infamy and
to death, and that
for nothing except what
was and ought to be,
all in all, a sense of duty."
John Adams put aside
personal preferences.
He stood up to public pressure.
And he did his duty.
And moreover, he did it to
the best of his ability.
He didn't do his
grudging, minimal best.
He did his absolute best.
And the captain was acquitted,
and most of the soldiers were.
And those who were not
escaped the death penalty.
Now, John Adams did
these things as a lawyer.
But adhering to duty in the
face of a contrary personal or
political preference and in
the face of public pressure
to the contrary has
particular resonance
for the job of a judge.
A judge is obligated to
apply the law as it is,
and not as she
wishes it would be.
She is obliged to
follow the law,
even when her personal
preferences cut the other way
or when she will experience
great public criticism
for doing so.
I'm going to talk
about this with a focus
on the Supreme
Court, because those
are the cases with which you
will be the most familiar
and the judges who
you'll be familiar with.
We have been fortunate
in our history
to have justices who have
been willing to do their duty,
even when it may run against
their personal sympathies,
and even when it will subject
them to public criticism.
I'm going to give you an
example from a famous dissent--
the dissent of
Justice Robert Jackson
in the case of Korematsu
versus the United States.
That case challenged the
constitutionality of the order
commanding the exclusion of
the Japanese from certain areas
during World War II.
The imposition of curfews,
exclusions, and ultimately
the Japanese internment is
a stain on American history.
As a congressional commission
later described it,
the internment was motivated by
racial prejudice, war hysteria,
and a failure of
political leadership.
But the widespread
public support
for the Japanese internment
is reflected in the fact
that Earl Warren, who was
then governor of California
and later became our chief
justice, who led the court when
Brown versus the Board
of Education was decided,
supported the
Japanese internment.
It was a time of war and
people were carried away.
Now, the internment of the
Japanese derived its authority
from an executive order that had
been signed by Franklin Delano
Roosevelt. Robert Jackson
owed his career to Roosevelt.
Roosevelt had appointed
him to the three
jobs that are the most
prestigious that any lawyer can
have.
Robert Jackson appointed
him to be the solicitor
general of the United
States, the attorney
States, and he appointed him
to his seat on
the Supreme Court.
And in addition to their
professional relationship,
they were friends--
longtime friends.
They were both from New York.
Yet Jackson did
not allow whatever
personal loyalty or affection
that he had for Roosevelt
influence his
decision in that case.
Unfortunately, he
was in the minority.
His was a dissent.
The Court decided 6-3
that the exclusion order
was constitutional.
But Jackson wrote
a vehement dissent,
objecting to the
constitutionality
of an order that rounded
up people, many of them,
most of them American
citizens, simply because they
were of Japanese descent.
He argued that that
could not be justified
as an exercise of
military power.
There had been no
suspension of habeas corpus.
And that is the provision
in the Constitution
that permits the exercise of
that kind of emergency power.
Duty, not politics.
Being a judge takes courage--
the courage of Robert Jackson.
You are not there to decide
cases as you may prefer.
You are not there to
decide cases as the public
or as the press may want you to.
You're not there to win
a popularity contest.
You are there to do your duty
and to follow the law wherever
it may take you.
Justice Scalia used to
say that a judge who
likes every result
that she reaches
is not a very good judge.
In fact, she's a very bad judge.
The law simply does not
align with a judge's
political preference or personal
preference in every case.
And so it will be
the case that judges
have to make hard decisions and
that they have to decide cases
in ways that yield
outcomes that are not
the outcomes they would prefer.
I've been at this only for
about a year and a half.
And I can attest that that
has happened to me many times
already.
But that is the
duty of a judge--
to decide cases in the
way that the law requires
them to be decided, and
not simply from the hip.
If I'm saying, what
would Amy Barrett
like to see the result
in this case be?
If the judge is willing
not to apply the law
but to decide cases in
a line, in accordance
with personal preference
rather than the law,
then she's not actually
functioning as a judge at all.
She's functioning
as a policymaker.
The fact that every judge
wears a nondescript black robe,
I think, is a powerful
testament to this fact.
It symbolizes the impersonality
of the law and the dedication
that each judge should
have to the rule of law.
The black robe
was not the custom
of the nation at its beginning.
At the start, judges--
including federal judges,
including the first justices
of the Supreme Court--
wore colored robes.
They would wear red robes
trimmed in ermine in the custom
of British judges.
Or some of them
wore robes that were
in the colors of the
academic institution
from which they had
graduated, so much
like academics when they
wear regalia at commencement.
So that was the custom
of judges at the time.
But John Marshall, who was
not our first chief justice
but was the foundational
and probably
the greatest of chief
justices, is the one
who changed that tradition.
At John Marshall's
investiture, he showed up
wearing a simple black robe.
And soon thereafter, his
brethren, the other members
of the Court, followed suit.
And today, all federal judges
wear a simple black robe
in deciding cases when they sit.
So why do I think
that's important?
Why do I think that reflects
the symbol of the impersonality
of the law?
Because the focus should not
be who is deciding the case.
The focus shouldn't
be on the judge.
The judge shouldn't
be drawing attention
to herself or himself.
The focus should be on the law.
The judge should be
deciding the case
not in accordance
with her personal,
with her individual preferences.
So the black robe doesn't
express individuality.
And a judge should not be
deciding cases in accordance
with her individual preferences.
The black robe symbolizes that
all judges share a dedication
to the rule of law,
that we are engaged
in a common enterprise
of applying the law
and doing our best job at it.
Justice should not turn
on what judge you get.
It should turn on
what the law requires.
Now, you might be saying
to yourselves, well, that's
all and good.
But judges are human.
Human beings have preferences.
Human beings have commitments.
And how could human
beings ever separate out
what their personal preferences
are from what the law requires?
I insist that that is possible.
It is something that every
judge must be vigilant about.
But it isn't possible.
That is the nature of the job.
And that is the judicial duty.
[CLAPPING]
[LAUGHING]
I'm going to share with you
a couple of my own techniques
that I use to try to guard
against any sort of bias.
When I write an opinion,
I try to view it
through the eyes of the party
that I'm ruling against,
through the losing party.
So I try to imagine that
it is me or someone I love.
Let's imagine it's a
criminal case, that it's
one of my own children
who is on the other side,
to try to check
and make sure, am I
deciding this case in
the most honest way,
and not out of any personal
bias or personal sympathy?
If this was someone who I
loved who was on the line,
could I honestly say that
this reasoning-- obviously I
would want to decide the case
in favor of my child, right?
But could I honestly say
that this reasoning is one
that I would apply to
someone that I loved dearly?
And I do the same
thing for colleagues
that might disagree with me.
So the job of judges is
to sift through arguments.
Sometimes the
arguments in a case,
especially at the
Court of Appeals level,
will be pretty one-sided.
And there'll be
pretty easy agreement
among the three-judge panel
about what the law requires.
But the cases are
sometimes closer,
and there will be good
arguments on either side.
And it's the job of the judge
to decide which of the arguments
is better.
And as I draft an opinion
in that kind of case,
I do it with an eye towards
what colleagues who are likely
to disagree with me.
What would the dissent think?
Do my arguments hold up?
Have I really given due
weight to everything
on the other side?
What will the dissent
say about this?
And if I write the
opinion that way,
I am really giving the
arguments on the other side
their full due.
Because when a judge has tunnel
vision, when a judge makes
a knee-jerk decision about how
a case should be decided based
on how the judge wants
to see it decided,
then the judge has
a hard time guarding
against that risk of personal
preferences creeping in.
It's only when the judge
disciplines herself
to really consider the best
legal arguments on both sides
of a question that the judge
can do her best job at trying
to make sure she is adhering to
that duty of following the law
wherever the law may lead.
Our foundational
constitutional commitment
is to the rule of law.
And for more than two
centuries, the federal judiciary
has worked assiduously, if
not always successfully,
has worked very hard
and mostly successfully
to develop and uphold
the rule of law.
We have an amazing Constitution.
And we have an amazing
judicial system.
We should be proud of it.
And we want it to continue.
For my own part,
I became a judge
to contribute to that tradition.
And I would have had
no interest in the job
if the job was
about policymaking
and about making
policy decisions.
My interest is in contributing
to our tradition of judges
upholding the rule of law.
And there's a lot of talk
these days about the courts
being mere political
institutions.
But if we reduce the
courts to mere politics,
then why do we need them?
We already have politicians.
Courts are not
arenas for politics.
Courts are places where
judges discharge the duty
to uphold the rule of law.
I'm going to stop there and then
invite my student, Stephanie,
to come up.
And we'll just have a little
bit of back and forth.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHANIE MALONEY:
So to start, I'd
like to talk with you about
the confirmation process.
AMY CONEY BARRETT: OK.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: It
wasn't that long ago
that you went through it.
And there was a lot
of media discussion
about whether the faith
of a judicial nominee
is relevant in the
confirmation process.
You yourself got quite a bit
of attention on that question.
So what role, if any, should
faith of a nominee have
in the confirmation process?
AMY CONEY BARRETT: None.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: Say more.
That's not enough.
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Yeah.
I wouldn't have let you get
away with a one-word answer.
None.
I mean, we have a long
tradition of religious tolerance
in this country.
And in fact, the religious
test clause in the Constitution
makes it unconstitutional
to impose a religious test
on anyone who holds
public office.
So whether someone is Catholic
or Jewish or Evangelical or
Muslim or has no faith at
all is irrelevant to the job.
And in fact, it's
unconstitutional to consider it
as a qualification for office.
I think there's been a lot
of public debate about that.
So I don't think I
have much more to add.
I think that that's just clear.
I do have one thing that I
want to add to that, though.
I think when you
step back and you
think about the debate about
whether someone's religion has
any bearing on their
fitness for office,
it seems to me that the
premise of the question
is that people of faith would
have a uniquely difficult time
separating out their
moral commitments
from their obligation
to apply the law.
And I think people of faith
should reject that premise.
All people, of course--
well, we hope, most people--
have deeply held
moral convictions,
whether or not they
come from faith.
People who have no faith,
people who are not religious,
have deeply held
moral convictions.
And it's just as important
for those people to be sure--
I just spent time talking
about the job of a judge being
to set aside moral convictions,
personal moral convictions
and personal preferences,
and follow the law.
That's a challenge
for those of faith
and for those who have no faith.
So I think the public should
be absolutely concerned about
whether a nominee
for judicial office
will be willing and able to
set aside personal preferences,
be they moral, be
they political,
whatever convictions they are.
The public should be concerned
about whether a nominee can
set those aside in favor
of following the law.
But that's not a challenge
just for religious people.
I mean, that's a
challenge for everyone.
And so I think it's
a dangerous road
to go down to say that only
religious people would not
be able to separate out moral
convictions from their duty.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: So in
the same way that you just
answered-- we separate
faith from the law.
You talked about how we
separate politics from the law.
So how does that map onto the
number of five-four decisions
in the Court, which
seem to often break down
along partisan lines?
Would you say that the Court
is becoming more politicized?
AMY CONEY BARRETT:
No, I wouldn't.
And that's obviously a
popular narrative right now.
And it has been at
other points in history.
As I tell my students,
when in my former life
as a constitutional
law professor,
I think that those
differences are not
about partisan politics.
I don't know any judges
who come to the bench
with the aim of
saying, I am going
to bring into
effect the platform
of the party with maybe
which I was once affiliated.
That's not true of those
who have been nominated
by Democratic presidents.
And that's not true of those
who have been nominated
by Republican presidents.
So I don't think that five-four
decisions or splits on courts
are explicable by
partisan commitments
or by outcomes in
particular cases.
I think they're explicable
by starting points,
by first-order commitments.
So there are differences
in ways that judges
approach the enterprise of
interpreting the Constitution.
I'll give you a
couple of examples.
All judges think that
the original meaning
of the Constitution--
its history, the way
that it was understood
by those who ratified
it, who drafted it,
the founding generation--
all judges take that as a
data point, as relevant.
Those who are committed
to originalism
treat it as determinative
when the original meaning
is discernible.
Others just treat
it as a data point,
but one that would not
necessarily control.
So that will yield different
outcomes in different cases.
It's the same thing with
constitutional text.
Some judges take an approach
to the text that says, listen.
If the text is clear,
that's non-negotiable.
Others take an
approach to the text
that treats it as
having a little bit
more play in the joints.
OK?
Some judges approach
the Constitution saying,
there are some
constitutional commitments
that we're not
going to back down
from because the
Constitution enshrines them.
But with respect to those
that the Constitution does not
speak, we're going to leave
it to democratic majorities
to work out.
Others see the
Constitution as having
a more amorphous
and evolving content
and speaking to evolving
values and majority--
evolving values in ways that
then democratic majorities
don't have the freedom
to make choices.
So they're just
different approaches
to constitutional
interpretation that
will yield different results
in many hot-button cases.
But that's a lot
different than saying,
well, it's because
such and such a judge
goes in and has these
particular five commitments that
are consistent with
the Democratic Party
platform or the
Republican Party platform.
So it's really a difference
in one's understanding
of the Constitution and
of the role of a judge.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: So
you spoke a little bit
about the way in which you
approach opinion writing, how
you separate your
personal preferences
and take an objective view.
When President Obama
nominated Justice Sotomayor
to the Supreme Court,
he famously said
that judges should be shaped by
empathy as much as by reason,
and that, quote, "a common
touch of compassion," end quote,
is a necessary ingredient
in a justice or a judge.
So do you think empathy or
compassion have a role to play?
Do they have a role to
play in legal reasoning
and legal writing?
AMY CONEY BARRETT:
Well, I think empathy
and compassion
have a role to play
in the life of every
human being, right?
I mean, we should
all be empathetic,
and we should all
be compassionate.
And as people, I
think that's something
that we want to encourage.
Do I think it has a
role in legal reasoning?
I would say no.
I would say yes,
in this respect.
I don't think-- and I try when
I draft opinions to have this
in mind--
I don't think judges
should ever be harsh.
So I don't think--
I think you should
be compassionate
to the losing party
who might find it
difficult to read the opinion.
I'm aware that the
party I'm ruling against
will read the opinion.
And so I want it to
be not worded harshly,
to be phrased in a way
that's kind and easy to take.
But should the law be driven
by compassion or empathy?
And I would say
the answer to that
is no, because
that gets mixed up
in the judge's personal
preferences or feelings.
So I think when the
law requires a result,
sometimes the law requires
results that are hard.
I think sometimes that the
penalties or the sentences
that statutes impose
for particular crimes--
I think this would be something
that district judges face
all the time when they
sentence criminal defendants.
Sometimes they don't have
a lot of discretion because
of the system that the statute
sets, in terms of how long
the sentence must be.
And that might be very hard for
them to impose that sentence.
But if that's what
the law requires,
you can't have judges
saying, that's not
what I'm going to do because
my heart tells me otherwise.
So I think what we want
in judges, again, is
judges who will follow the law.
And we want to be
compassionate people.
We certainly want to be aware
of the effect of our decisions.
But I think you get
into a dangerous place
when you say that you're going
to follow your heart and not
your head in deciding a case.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: You've talked
about, at least in conversation
with me, about how frequently
the Seventh Circuit writes
opinions.
And you yourself have written
quite a few in criminal cases.
Is that something that has
informed your approach,
in terms of paying attention to
the language that you're using
and whether you're coming across
as harsh in those opinions?
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Sure.
I try to be conscious
when I write the opinions
that the people who I'm
writing that-- let's
imagine that I'm
affirming a conviction
or affirming a sentence.
If it were my child whose
conviction was being affirmed
or whose sentence
was being affirmed,
I would want the opinion
written in a very respectful
and well-reasoned way,
and not in a snide way
or to use it as an opportunity
to get some cute lines in
or something like that.
So yeah.
I think it's very
important to realize
this is serious
business that you're
entrusted with, heavy
responsibility as a judge.
And so you should write
your opinions accordingly.
This is real stuff, and
people's liberty on the line.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: You've
had one opinion that
drew some-- many
opinions that drew
attention, one in particular
that I'd like to talk about.
You wrote a dissent in
Kanter versus Barr, which
was a Second Amendment case.
And in your dissent, you
studied founding era documents.
Can you talk a little
bit about the background
of the case for those of us
who are unfamiliar with it?
And then talk
about your approach
to those large
constitutional questions.
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Sure.
So Kanter versus Barr was a case
in which the defendant-- well,
he had been convicted
of Medicaid fraud.
He had sold shoe inserts
that didn't actually
comply with the right
standards and then
been refunded, gotten
money for them anyway.
It was fraud.
And he had served his sentence.
But under federal
law, those who've
been convicted of a
felony, of any felony,
lose their gun
rights, so that they
can't possess a gun thereafter.
So Kanter argued that
he wasn't a threat.
This was his only conviction.
It wasn't a violent crime.
He had discharged his sentence.
He didn't use
illegal substances.
He was stable.
He had a job.
He was married.
And time had passed
since this conviction.
And he was not a recidivist.
So he argued that it was
unconstitutional to deprive
him of his Second
Amendment right
to possess a firearm because
he did not pose any danger.
And the three-judge panel, two
of my colleagues rejected that
claim and said that the Second
Amendment doesn't preclude--
in Kanter's case, there was both
a state statute from Wisconsin
and then a federal statute
that made it illegal for felons
to possess guns.
So the majority said that
that was constitutional.
And I wrote a dissent saying
that it was unconstitutional.
It's unusual, at the
Court of Appeals level,
to encounter a
case which requires
a deep dive into
founding era documents,
because at the Court
of Appeals level,
so many cases have already been
decided by the Supreme Court
that you're typically
applying precedent.
You're applying Supreme
Court precedent.
The Second Amendment
is newer territory.
The Supreme Court decided Heller
versus United States just--
Heller versus District of
Columbia-- not that long ago.
And it's only taken one
other Second Amendment case
since then.
So there's just not a lot
of precedent out there.
So I had to do a pretty
deep dive into the history
of the Second Amendment.
And Heller, the
Supreme Court case,
is pretty clear about the fact
that the scope of the Second
Amendment needs to be
determined by its history.
And I concluded, after
serving all of the arguments--
the historically-based arguments
for the constitutionality
of depriving felons of their
right to possess firearms--
that there was no
blanket authorization
to just take guns, that the
right to possess a gun away
from someone who
committed a felony.
That sounds kind of radical, to
say felons can have firearms.
But I think it's because what
the longstanding prohibitions
were, and in fact, had
been, even under federal law
until more recently, was
that violent felons couldn't
have firearms.
And there's a longstanding--
what the history showed me was
that there's been a longstanding
practice of saying that those
who pose a threat of violence
to the community cannot have
firearms.
And that makes sense, right?
History is consistent
with commonsense.
Those who would be
risky with guns,
who would pose danger
with guns, then the state
can take guns away.
But in the instance of
someone who the state has not
shown that the person
has demonstrated
any risk, the mere status of
having committed a felony,
I found no historical
support for saying
that the state was then
justified in taking it away.
So as I said, in that opinion,
if the state had evidence
that Mr. Kanter would have
posed some threat of violence
if he'd had a gun, then that
would be a different situation.
But the mere fact that
someone had committed a felony
wasn't enough.
And you know,
over-criminalization
gets a lot of talk these days.
And when you look at the number
of things that are felonies,
you can--
it's a felony-- now I'm
kind of talking out the hip.
And I'll see if I can remember
exactly which state it was.
I think it was Massachusetts
that made selling
pigs without a license--
returning out-of-state bottles
for deposits in Michigan
can be a felony when it's
over a certain amount.
So there's not really a
limit on what states can
choose to define as felonies.
And so it seems a
little bit odd to say
that the scope of one's
Second Amendment right
would depend on what a state
chooses to define as a felony
or not.
So I concluded that
the line really
isn't whether someone
is a felon or not.
But the line is really whether
someone is dangerous or not.
Dangerous people
shouldn't have guns.
But simply saying that
someone has committed a felony
isn't a good enough
reason, without markers
of dangerousness.
But it was hard.
I mean, at the Supreme Court,
when I clerked, it's even,
I think, become
truer and truer, you
have so many briefs from amici.
So friends of the
court will file briefs.
And they will give you all
this historical research.
And you have
excellent advocates.
And so the Court has less
groundwork of its own
to do because the
briefing is so rich.
And the same is not true
at the Court of Appeals.
You just don't have all these
amicus briefs coming in.
So my law clerks and I had to
do a lot of research on our own.
So it was a heavy lift.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: I bet there
are some upcoming law review
articles about
them, [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you're looking at
founding era documents,
would you describe
yourself as an originalist?
And if so, could you describe
your view of originalism,
what that means to you?
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Yeah.
Yeah, I do consider myself
to be an originalist.
And my view of
originalism, you know,
originalists have two
basic commitments.
One is that the meaning of the
law is fixed as of the time
that it's ratified, and then
that the original meaning
of that law controls
if it's discernible.
So sometimes laws will have more
open-ended-- or constitutional
provisions, even-- might use
more open-ended language,
like the word reasonableness
in the Fourth Amendment.
Sometimes the language of
a constitutional provision
is clear.
And if the law is
clear, an originalist
would say that the judge
doesn't have the discretion
to depart from it.
So I do consider
myself originalist.
And I think when I
was in law school,
I think I started gravitating
towards that as a first year
when I took constitutional
criminal procedure.
And my professor was
not an originalist.
But that was my first exposure
to constitutional cases.
And I didn't know--
I didn't go to
Hillsdale College.
So I had not studied
originalism as an undergraduate.
So I wasn't familiar
when I entered law school
with originalism as a theory.
But I found myself, as I
read more and more cases,
becoming more and more convinced
that the opinions that I
read that took the originalist
approach were right.
And then as I progressed
through my studies
and then did more
theoretical work,
I became even more
convinced of that,
because that's where
the Constitution gets
its authority, right?
I mean, we agree to
live by the Constitution
until it's lawfully changed.
And judges can't change it.
That's not democratic, right?
We change it by the prescribed
process, which is Article V.
Now, the Constitution doesn't
answer every question.
And it gives a lot
of flexibility.
It gives that flexibility
to democratic majorities
to meet changing times
by passing legislation.
The Constitution
isn't the panacea that
cures every societal problem.
We have to trust our
political branches to do that.
STEPHANIE MALONEY:
One final question.
On a personal note, you are
a wife, mother of seven,
a law professor,
and a federal judge.
So can women really have it all?
[LAUGHTER]
And if you had to give advice
to young women at Hillsdale
and other universities
for pursuing
a career in the law, what
would that look like?
AMY CONEY BARRETT:
I think each woman
is called to a unique path.
I don't think there's
one cookie cutter
way that women should proceed.
And I didn't know exactly what
I wanted my life to look like.
It kind of became a
work-- it was always,
it still is a work in progress.
We will celebrate
the 100th anniversary
of the 19th Amendment
next year, which
gave women the right to vote.
And I think that we should
celebrate the ability of women
to not only cast their
ballots, but to participate
in both the private and the
public spheres in so many ways
that our grandmothers
were not able to.
So yes.
[APPLAUSE]
But one thing I
often think, when--
I'll get asked this
question a lot,
as I think most
working mothers do,
about balancing
career and family.
One thing I think that is really
important not to lose sight of
is that we are so
fortunate, as women living
in 2019, to have so many more
doors open to us and so many
choices.
But I think as part
of that conversation,
I always want to
be careful never
to devalue the choices that
women make that are different.
Women shouldn't have
to be cookie cutters.
So some women have
the flexibility
to be able to stay
home with children.
I have seven
children and I'm also
the oldest of seven children.
And I have five sisters.
And three of us work full-time,
two of us work part-time,
and one stays home
with her children.
And she homeschools them.
And she probably works
harder than the rest of us.
So I think we should
celebrate and try
to make possible and support
and think creatively about ways
to provide childcare for women
who are in the workplace.
And then I think we should
also celebrate the choices,
like my sister, Eileen, who
is home with her children,
and my own mother, make to
stay home with their children.
I just think that one
freedom that we should really
celebrate as women is that
we don't have to just follow
a path that seems like the
one that people tell us
that we have to follow.
And we don't just have to
think what people tell us
that we might have to think as
women, that we're really free.
And that if you want
to live a life that
looks a little bit different,
I mean, you know, my friend--
I have seven children.
Two of them are
adopted from Haiti
and our youngest
has Downs syndrome.
And when my son,
Benjamin, was born
and he was in the NICU,
my friend, my dear
friend who I've known for a
long time, was sitting with me--
it was a very difficult
time, he was on oxygen--
just holding my hand.
She looked up at me
and she said, do you
have to be so competitive?
You already had the most
interesting Christmas card
on the mantle.
[LAUGHTER]
We can make choices
to have a life that
looks different or odd.
I mean, you can be
free to be different.
And you can stay home with
children or you can work.
But you should
respect the choices
that all women make in that
regard and the contributions
that all women contribute.
STEPHANIE MALONEY: Do you have
any final closing thoughts?
AMY CONEY BARRETT:
Gosh, I don't think so.
I'm just so grateful that
you all came tonight.
And it was wonderful
to be with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW SPALDING: OK.
Thank you, Judge.
And thank you, Stephanie,
for that interview.
That was wonderful.
I have two things for you.
One is, it's not Notre Dame
green, but it's Hillsdale blue.
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Thank you.
I'll treasure it.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW SPALDING:
And of course, I
do have a last final, final
question for you, which
is, what is your position
about Hillsdale students
as law clerks, and--
[LAUGHTER]
AMY CONEY BARRETT:
Send them to me.
MATTHEW SPALDING: Thank you.
And thank all those--
a lot of people are
watching our live streaming,
both on campus and elsewhere.
I thank them for joining us.
Thank you all for joining us.
And have a wonderful evening.
Thank you very much.
AMY CONEY BARRETT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]